one of Carter's most iconic landmarks
the Museum of Islamic Art widely known
as the Mia has reopened after more than
a year of renovations
designed by renowned architect I am pay
the building itself is considered a work
of art
many of the renovations are subtle with
great efforts made to preserve the
original vision for the Museum's look
the entrance has been widened and opened
up as part of the redesign but the
biggest changes are in the Galleries and
the way the artifacts are displayed
the Mia's Grand Atrium houses 18
galleries bringing together thousands of
artifacts from across the Islamic world
one of the challenges was making this
accessible to a wide audience
to put it this way we had beautiful
objects they were in beautiful showcases
but there was very little story and
context about them so what we did is
first of all we introduced a visitor
Trail so people follow a trail and have
a little story if you followed closely
you get an idea about you know the
Islamic world the culture the history
the religion we introduced religion for
example there is nothing on religion
before
One path pulls the spread of Islam from
the printed word
to Artistic creations
to the development of an Islamic
community there's also been a push to
appeal to an international audience
One path takes visitors from the
Mediterranean to the gulf through to
Iran and Beyond the Indian oceans and
Southeast Asia are also totally new we
never had southeast Asia in the Indian
Ocean but specifically with the audience
here and with so many people from this
area and being you know Indonesia being
one of the biggest
Muslim countries in the world we really
thought that should be included
the curators also want to stimulate the
senses there are plans to enhance
displays with video music and even
smells
special exhibitions are being mounted to
coincide with the World Cup
one focuses on Baghdad
the Iraqi Capital was once the jewel of
Arab culture so it's an appropriate
Choice as Doha briefly becomes the
center of the sports world
Cather plans to open at least three more
major museums by 2030 a bush to
consolidate its place as one of the
cultural capitals of the modern Middle
East
Vinton Monahan Al Jazeera Doha